l'Ukraine n'a pas encore lancé ses
grandes manœuvres la Russie affirme le
contraire dans une déclaration très
solennelle Moscou annonce avoir déjouer
une percée militaire dans la région du
handball
au total si bataillons mobiles les deux
chars ennemis ont participé à cette
opération le but de l'ennemi était de
percer nos défenses dans les secteurs
les plus vulnérables du front l'ennemi
n'a pas accompli ses tâches il a échoué
l'Ukraine prépare depuis des mois sa
contre-offensive pour récupérer ses
territoires perdus et le fait savoir
mais maintiens volontairement le flot
sur la date de son lancement l'armée
ukrainienne aura besoin d'un appui
renforcé des alliés occidentaux pour
soutenir cette opération militaire
depuis le début de la guerre le conflit
tue autant les soldats que les civils
admis pro dans le centre de l'Ukraine
des bombardements survenus samedi en
coûté la vie à une petite fille de 2 ans
qui se trouvait chez elle drague
à des centaines de nos enfants depuis le
24 février au moins 485 en France sont
morts c'est un chiffre que nous pouvons
officiellement
plus élevé chaque fois que nous libérons
notre terre des occupants russes nous
découvrons les horreurs qui se sont
déroulées sous le truc
selon les autorités une vingtaine de
personnes ont été blessées dont des
enfants au moins trois sont dans un état
préoccupant